Humans keep developing more and more
powerful weapons and weapons,
the ones they drones,
and then our itinerary came along.
Alan's quite literally blew everything
else out of the water.
And now today with airplanes,
satellites,
submarines and missiles,
we have a gain that be changed the way
we make this in facts,
military innovation has produced many
important technological advances,
but it all does have a limit.
The destructive effects of weapons of
mass destruction or wmds has forced
rules to limit their use of their
production and their storage as well.
This is completely necessary if we don't
want the planet to be well completely
destroyed,
fight against nuclear proliferation.
Wmds can be biological,
chemical,
radiological,
and nuclear,
but the biggest problem we face are
these nuclear weapons.
This is due to their sheer destructive
power and because thousands and
thousands of them were accumulated
during the arms race in the Cold War,
we will develop a larger and more
accurate c based ballistic missile.
We will also deploy nuclear cruise
missiles in some existing submarines in
the 1960s seventies and eighties art and
music and the civil movements took
action against nuclear weapons.
Maybe you remember flower power or at
least you've probably heard of it.
Okay.
Songs which best represents the story of
these years and they do recommend that
you've got to listen to them.
If you haven't already know,
La Gay by orchestral maneuvers in the
dark ends,
99 red balloons.
Real challenge today is keeping North
Korea or Iran from continuing that
programs to develop wmds and further to
keep such weapons out of the hands of
terrorist organizations.
A nuclear crisis in Korea would be a
tragedy and it would certainly affect
globalization,
trade and all very lifestyles.
Now the problem here is quite condensed
and we should really analyze it from a
global perspective.
As we said,
there are international rules which
limits to the acquisition of nuclear
weapons.
These rules are classified into two
different categories,
horizontal nonproliferation.
This is meant to prevents countries
which don't have these weapons from
obtaining them and then there is
vertical nonproliferation and this is
meant to stop states already in
possession of nuclear weapons,
especially the US and Russia from
increasing the number of nuclear weapons
they have and even encouraging,
reducing the stock piles,
horizontal non-proliferation.
The NP
horizontal
nonproliferation tries to prevent a new
countries from joining the nuclear club
as obviously it's specifically aims to
prevent countries like Iran,
North Korea,
well as terrorist organizations from
getting these weapons.
Yes.
You might remember now that we did
another video on this where we talked
about how the rules aren't really
working so well in the case of North
Korea.
Well,
this is what the NPT has achieved since
1968 in the early sixties it was
estimated that by the year 2000 around
20 countries would hold nuclear weapons.
Many countries like Algeria,
Roger,
Dina,
Brazil,
Spain,
and Sweden had the ability to develop
these weapons.
However,
thanks to the NPT and international
leverage,
very few states are in possession of
these weapons today.
Yeah,
clear non proliferation treaty
established at the five permanent
members of the Security Council,
which at first where the United States,
the Soviet Union,
China,
France,
and United Kingdom.
We're the only nuclear powers and it
forbade other states from acquiring
nuclear weapons.
It looks great.
The members of the nuclear club,
the five nuclear powers would commit to
help the rest of the countries develop
nuclear energy for civil public.
However,
with time and despite all of this,
some countries have succeeded in
becoming nuclear powers today.
Besides the five powers previously
mentioned,
four more countries have developed
nuclear weapons.
That's Israel,
India,
Pakistan,
and to North Korea.
And then there's Iran,
which also try it.
You'll probably know that during the
Ahmadinejad administration,
Iran tried to develop one of these
bombs,
and this would have meant there would be
a significant threat to both Israel as
well as the Middle Eastern Region.
But fortunately,
the international community took action
to flank that possibility and the
sanctions leveled by the Security
Council,
damaged Iran's oil and gas exports and
badly and all of that international
pressure.
It has an impact because in the next
elections,
Rohani became the president of the
country.
He was a more moderate candidates to
very harsh negotiations.
In 2015 they reached an agreement in
which Iran stopped its nuclear agenda
and in exchange,
the rest of the countries would lift
sanctions on exports,
which was good news in a country like
Iran or wary lack of exports was causing
significant damage to its economy.
Well,
now we come to North Korea ans maybe we
should let it to leader speak for
himself.
Median Kim doing it.
Don't get caught.
Some God that he does.
We don't exactly know what weapons North
Korea possesses or there's some
estimates say as we mentioned in a
previous video,
could it's from 10 to 20 bombs.
These are unsophisticated but still
powerful enough to trigger a significant
crisis.
For this reason,
the United Nations Security Council has
strengthened the penalty system for
North Korea after the last underground
detonation in September of 2016 the
presses even dead to speculates that the
might be preventative and military
action against North Korea by the trump
administration.
However,
American experts are wanting this
military action could trigger a military
response with wmds as well as
conventional weaponry or war in the
Korean peninsula would mean a human
catastrophe and it would negatively
affect the world's economy.
It would most of all affected neighbors,
China,
south,
and Japan,
and the mere existence of this threat of
war could lead to a terrifying arms race
in the region and it could even make
Japan take exceptional measures.
This is something we've talked about in
a previous video that you can see here.
That is why it's important for China to
end it's friendly relationship with
North Korea.
It's not going to end well for China.
More overwhelmed,
general vertical non-proliferation.
Wow,
awesome.
A vertical nonproliferation.
During the Cold War,
the u s and the Soviet Union developed
more and more powerful nuclear weapons
in greater and greater numbers.
Each country needed to have more into
better weapons than the other two.
These stored thousands and thousands of
nuclear warheads.
They also increased their means of
delivering aircraft,
missile submarines all to an extent that
had previously not even been imagined
during the cold war arms race.
The global nuclear stockpile peaked in
1986 at about 70,000
nuclear warheads according to the
Federation of American scientists,
enough to destroy the earth several
times.
Okay.
In Louisiana is the woman he tests with
nuclear weapons conducted in the
atmosphere,
in the sea,
in space,
and sometimes whether intentionally or
not,
they used people as Guinea pigs do
analyze the effects of radioactivity in
humans.
It was all a pretty terrible time.
The Japanese artist Hashimoto has
prepared a video where you can see the
different nuclear tests since 1945
it looks like a video game,
but it's not.
Fortunately with the end of the Cold
War,
the United States and Russia agreed to
reduce the nuclear arsenals as well as
their means of delivery.
Under President Obama written April,
2010 the staunch treaty was signed in
Prague.
This treaty agency limit strategic
weapons,
so each country would only hold 1,500
nuclear bombs like the year 2018 but
still that is way too many bombers.
There are also other rules to limit
missiles and means of delivery and of
course,
no more nuclear testing is permitted.
So ctbt is a treaty which completely
forbids any nuclear tests and no more
tests have been carried out since 1998
with the exception of course being North
Korea.
Anyway,
the conclusion of all of this is that
yes,
we must definitely stop the
proliferation of nuclear weapons in Iran
or North Korea and we sat and we have to
prevent terrorist groups from laying
their hands on these WMDs,
but the nuclear arsenals that still
exist in the u s and Russia should also
keep reducing because among other
things,
the risk of misuse and lack of control
of these weapons is waste presence in
the world we inhabit today and to
dependence and globalized wars.
They don't make any steps.
Bernard Brodie,
the North American strategist already
said this after World War II
thus far.
The chief purpose of our military
establishment has been to when Moore's
from now on its chief purpose must be to
avert them
in the u s president John F.
Kennedy was a pioneer in the search of
peace and nuclear disarmament.
Okay.
Too many of us think it is impossible to
many think it is unreal,
but that is a dangerous your fetus
believe.
It leads to the conclusion that war is
inevitable,
that mankind is doomed,
that we are gripped by forces we cannot
control.
We need not accept that view our
problems,
a manmade,
therefore they can be solved by man
in a world dominated by nuclear weapons.
Kennedy's he refused to conduct any
nuclear tests in the atmosphere and he
was criticized for that in his own
country.
However,
we could have avoided so much suffering
and saved a huge amount of money if the
wells had just listened to Kennedy's
ideas on nuclear weapons.
So I really hope you enjoyed that video.
If you did,
please do hit that like button below.
And don't forget to subscribe if you
haven't already for brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday.
Also,
please do not forget to check out our
friends at the reconsidered media
podcasts who provide the voice on this
video that isn't my own,
and as always,
I look forward to seeing you in the next
week.
[inaudible].